en el vídeo pasado teníamos un protón
que se movía como a un quinto de la
velocidad de la luz y entraba a este
campo magnético de magnitud 0.5 teclas
que apuntaba hacia afuera de la pantalla
hacia ti utilizando esto y la formulita
de por acá determinamos la magnitud de
la fuerza que ejerce este campo sobre el
protón y vimos que era de 4.8 x es al
menos 12 newtons y además utilizando la
regla de la mano derecha
vimos que esa fuerza era perpendicular a
la velocidad y que iba hacia abajo en
este plano después que pasaba bueno pues
lo que sucedía era que esa fuerza hacia
que esta partícula se desviará tantito
que este protón se hiciera tantito para
abajo y que además su velocidad cambiará
ligeramente para entonces que iba
pasando un momento a momento pues que la
velocidad iba girando y que sucedía
ahora pues bueno esta partícula todavía
estaba aquí en el plano seguía en el
mismo plano que es la pantalla y seguía
pues seguía estando por aquí este campo
magnético entonces pues ese campo
magnético seguía ejerciendo una fuerza
con la
magnitud pero como en la partícula ya se
movió tantito y su velocidad cambio pues
ahora la fuerza la nueva fuerza pues va
a seguir siendo perpendicular pero va a
tener otra dirección porque la velocidad
también cambió de dirección puedes
imaginar que la mano derecha la giramos
tantito y que ahora para acá estaba el
dedo índice vale bueno de cualquier
forma la velocidad nos quedaba
perpendicular va y entonces pues ese
cambio de velocidad lo que hubo bueno y
ese cambio de fuerza lo que nos daban es
que había una fuerza centrípeta quienes
estaba haciendo ejercida sobre este
protón y por lo tanto lo hacía ir en
círculos muy bien eso es lo del vídeo
pasado y dijimos que en este vídeo
íbamos a decir pues bueno y vamos a
calcular el radio del círculo en el cual
se movía ese protón hay ya pinte el
círculo y déjame marcar el radio
entonces lo que nos interesa es calcular
este radio de acá vale a ese radio
déjame ponerle r y para hacer esto vamos
a tener que desempolvar nuestra caja de
herramientas de hace mucho tiempo cuando
empezamos los videos en donde hablábamos
acerca pues de fuerzas centrípetas y de
radios de circunferencias eso fue hace
muchos muchos vídeos pero espero que
todavía nos acordemos y decía más o
menos así la aceleración la aceleración
centrípeta estaba dada por la magnitud
de la velocidad elevada al cuadrado
dividida entre el radio de la
circunferencia que se describía esto ya
que era la aceleración centrípeta bueno
su magnitud que entonces si queremos
encontrar la magnitud de la fuerza
tenemos que multiplicar esto por la más
porque fuerza es igual a la masa por
aceleración vale entonces esto de aquí
sería igual a la fuerza centrípeta y
aquí cuanto sabemos que es esa fuerza
esa magnitud de la de la fuerza
centrípeta pues es justo esta expresión
de acá verdad los 4.8 por 10 a la menos
12 newtons entonces esto es igual
a 4.8 por 10 al menos 12 newton muy bien
pero lo que nosotros queremos encontrar
es el radio el radio de la
circunferencia entonces vamos a
despejarlo lo primero que voy a hacer
aquí es cambiar numerador y denominador
de ambos lados o sea voltear y pues
estas fracciones entonces nos quedaría
que el radio dividido entre la magnitud
de la velocidad al cuadrado multiplicado
por la masa déjame ponerlo la masa si x
la masa es igual a 1 entre 4.8 4.8 por
10 a la menos 12 va este numerito no sé
cuánto sea ahorita metemos toda la carga
primero déjame acabar de despejar
entonces ahora multiplicando por la
velocidad por la magnitud de la
velocidad al cuadrado por la masa de
ambos lados entonces nos quedaría que el
radio es igual a la magnitud en la
velocidad al cuadrado
si quieres lo escribo un poco más grande
la magnitud de la velocidad al cuadrado
por la masa y eso dividido entre 4.8 4.8
por 10 a la menos 12 muy bien estoy acá
ya podemos meterlo a la calculadora
vamos a ver cuánto nos da que le va a
poner r es igual a y al final nos
deberían de quedar metros entonces dejas
al cola calvo está la calculadora
entonces la encendemos hay que meter
este numerito de acá la la masa del
protón pues bueno al menos yo no me lea
no me la he aprendido pero
afortunadamente la tengo aquí en la
variable m le puse alfa m
entonces 1.67 por 10 a la menos 27 bueno
vamos a ver cuánto nos da la operación
va entonces tendríamos que dejar de
poner el numerador entonces vamos a
poner m es la masa del protón
multiplicada por la velocidad al
cuadrado aquí tenemos la velocidad
entonces
10 a la 7
eso de allí cierro paréntesis lo elevó
al cuadrado y hay que hay que no hay que
dividirlo y eso hay que dividirlo entre
4.8 por 1010 a la
al menos 12 - 12 ojalá no quede bien
aquí debe ser un -2 ojalá no quede un
número muy feo 4.8 por 10 a la menos 12
le damos enter jamir esto está padrísimo
1.25 44 como todo está en sistema
internacional son metros entonces el
radio es de 1.25 metros eso está
padrísimo o sea si tenemos que un protón
viaja de un quinto de la velocidad de la
luz y entra a un campo magnético de 0.53
las 0.53 las que está apuntando hacia
afuera de la pantalla entonces tenemos
que ese protón va a describir un
movimiento circular con radio igual a
1.25 metros y eso está muy bueno porque
pues nos lo podemos imaginar eso está
súper súper padre bueno también quiero
platicarte un poquito acerca de las
aplicaciones de toda esta teoría y de
hecho te quiero hablar de aplicaciones
de cosas que si ves todos los días bueno
espero que no todos los días pero esto
de aquí se puede aplicar en la
televisión entonces esto está muy bonito
tiene aplicaciones en televisión no en
las televisiones nuevas
de pantalla de plasma y si no en las
televisiones más viejitas de las de
tubos de rayo catódico creo que así se
llama y más o menos la idea es que la
tele pues se emite un rayo de electrones
de hecho la podrías desarmar bueno no te
recomiendo que lo hagas de hecho podría
ser un poco peligroso porque hay un
vacío que puede hacer que la televisión
importe pero bueno ahí adentro de la
tele hay un imán que hace que se mueva
este rayo de electrones que hace que se
pasee por toda la pantalla y justo eso
es lo que genera imágenes ahorita no me
voy a meter mucho en los detalles quizás
sería bueno después hacer un vídeo de
cómo funcionan las televisiones pero
bueno esta es una aplicación otra
aplicación un poco más científica son
estas cosas que a lo mejor has escuchado
que son los aceleradores de partículas
en donde las hace mira muy altas
velocidades en trayectorias circulares y
las hacen chocar y a lo mejor alguna vez
te has preguntado cómo le hacen para que
un protón vaya en círculos si no es como
que agarran las pinzas y le empiezan a
dar vueltas sino que justo la idea es
que utilizan campos magnéticos
para que lo vayan aumentando y
aumentando su velocidad pasando por un
mismo lugar en realidad no soy experto
en este tema este es más o menos la idea
general pero bueno lo que sí sé es que
gastan miles de millones de dólares para
tener imágenes como ésta como ésta de
acá vale y justo pues aquí pueden ver
pues los radios de las circunferencias y
eso lo que les dice es más o menos qué
tipo de partícula es tienen que tomar
ciertas consideraciones relativistas
porque se mueven a velocidades tan altas
que hay que ajustar la masa pero bueno
eso es algo complicado otra vez no me
quiero meter en tantísimos detalles pero
la idea general es que bueno si puedes
si tienes su radio y si tienes su masa y
su velocidad pues eso más o menos te
ayuda a distinguir entre partículas vas
bueno ahora nada más como última cosa
quiero preguntarte lo siguiente qué
sucedería si éste en vez de ser un
protón fuera un electrón y todo lo demás
pues fuera lo mismo pues vamos a ver a
ver aquí tenemos esta fórmula de fuerza
la carga del protón pues es la misma que
la del electrón en valor absoluto sin
embargo
hay que ponerle un signo menos porque
ahora la carga del electrón bueno
ahorita vemos qué pasa con eso pero todo
lo demás es igual el ángulo es el mismo
el campo magnético tiene pues su misma
intensidad 0.5 teclas aquí también
tenemos pues este mismo elector
velocidad porque dijimos que eso es
exactamente lo mismo va entonces la
magnitud de la fuerza es la misma pero
ojo tiene otro signo aquí tendría que
tener un menos porque la carga del
electrón es negativa y entonces aunque
la aunque nuestra regla de la mano
derecha nos diga que la fuerza apunta
hacia abajo esa fuerza es negativa y por
lo tanto podemos pensarla como una
fuerza positiva pero hacia el otro lado
entonces qué pasaría ahora la fuerza
iría hacia allá y por lo tanto ahora el
círculo no seguiría esta dirección sino
que ahora la partícula el electrón se
desviaría hacia arriba entonces
tendríamos algo más o menos
y este estilo y pues ya nada más una
pregunta crees que este círculo tenga un
radio más grande o más chiquito
bueno pues vámonos a las cuentas la
velocidad es la misma este 4.8 por 10 a
la menos 12 es el mismo vale pero esta
masa va a ser la masa del electrón y la
masa de un electrón es más chiquita que
la de un protón de hecho es mucho más
chiquita entonces qué sucedería que el
radio ahora sería menor entonces
tendríamos un círculo más chiquito y que
va hacia el otro lado de hecho si
quieres encontrar la razón entre los
radios de estos círculos pues es justo
la razón entre la masa de un protón y la
masa de un electrón
bueno espero que te haya interesado
todas esas cosas que te conté en este
vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo
para hablar acerca para hablar más
acerca de magnetismo hasta la próxima